وفي مدينه حلفا شماليه السودان قرب الحدود
مع مصر يتكدس الاف السودانيين قرب
القنصليه المصريه مع فرض الجهات المصريه
تاشيره على الاطفال والنساء وكبار السن
مراسل الجزيره طاهر المرضي يرصد لنا
الموقف هناك اليك الطاهر
نعم الموقف في حلفا وفي القنصليه المصريه
هنا في حلفا هو موقف ووضعه ماساوي للغايه
خاصه وان العالقين في هذه المناطق بسبب
الحرب ويودون العبور الى مصر يواجهون
صعوبات كبيره سواء كان في الاقامه وحتى في
التاشيره الى مصر الان نحن نحدثكم من احد
مراكز اليواه وهو هنالك اكبر من او اكثر
من 30 مركز يضم عدد كبير من السودانيين
الذين يعانون اوضاع ماساويه بالنسبه
لهؤلاء هنالك ازمه مركبه في هذه المنطقه
اذا كانت الاجراءات التي يعني فرضتها
القنصليه المصريه على هؤلاء المواطنين
وتاخروا بسبب هذه الاجراءات بعد ان قامت
السلطات المصريه بتعديل اجراءات الدخول
الى مصر بفرط شراء على
الاطفال وعلى على النساء وهذا كان في
السابق وكبار السن وكان في السابق هو لا
توجد تاشيرات لهؤلاء ثم ان كانت هنالك
ايضا اتفاقيه بين السودان ومصر فيما يختص
بالحريات الاربعه وهي حريه التنقل التي هي
تضرر منها هؤلاء الموجودون هنا في هذه
المنطقه نحن في خلال هذه الجوله التي قمنا
بها في هذه المراكز مراكز تفتقر للحد
الادنى من الحياه الطبيعيه التي يمكن ان
تحافظ على يعني حياه الناس وغيرها هنالك
ازمه في المياه هنالك ازمه كبيره في
الرعايه هنالك غياب للمنظمات التي تستطيع
ان تقدم لهم المساعده هنالك عدد كبير من
المرضى يعانون حتى الان والمستشفى الوحيد
الموجود في هذه المدينه غير قادره انه
يقدم الخدمات بالنسبه لهؤلاء
العالقين وهم يعيشون هذه الظروف ارتفاع في
الاسعار بعضهم يعني نفذت منهم الاموال حتى
يستطيعون يعني
يقدموا هذه او يعولوا الاسر كذلك هنالك
قرار من السلطات المصريه او في القنصليه
هنا اذا كان الشخص لديه اطفال فعليه ان
يصطحب الثلاثه اطفال فقط ويترك البقيه
وهذا اصبح خيار صعب بالنسبه للاسر في مثل
هذه الظروف وهم يعتبرون هذه الاجراءات هي
اجراءات تعجيزيه لربما يعني قصدت منها
القنصليه عدم
السماح لهم
بالدخول الى الاراضي المصريه نحن نتحدث عن
جمله اشياء يعني هنالك يعني عدد كبير من
هؤلاء العالقين لديهم امراض مزمنه وبحسب
المصادر التي تحدثنا اليها في المعابر
توفي اكثر من 20 شخص بسبب هذه الامراض
المزمنه ويقول لنا ايضا مدير المستشفى في
حلفا ان اكثر من 15 شخص ايضا توفي في هذه
المستشفى اللي ذات الاسباب اذا نحن يعني
نشاهد مساحه حقيقيه لهؤلاء العالقين هنا
في حلفا وليس هنالك مؤشر لانفراج هذه
الازمه وكذلك هنالك انتظار اكبر وهنالك
ايضا يعني قرارات من السلطات ارجعت اعداد
كبيره منهم من المعابر في معبر ارجين
وغيره من المعابر وليس هنالك مؤشر لحل هذه
الازمه على الرغم من ان هذه الظروف
الانسانيه وتداعيات الحرب يعني والحزن
الذي يخيم عليهم بشكل كبير وتتفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه يوما بعد يوم في هذه المنطقه
الطاهر المرضي من مدينه حلفا الشماليه
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك